Українські військові окопуються на Миколаївщині. Цей підрозділ щойно зайняв нову позицію і тепер укріплює оборону, риє окопи.
Ми постійно здійснюємо спроби витіснити ворога з його позицій.
Ці спроби є вдалими і ми рухаємося вперед. Ми займаємо нові позиції, ми облаштовуємо їх. І ми таким чином рухаємося вперед.
Минуло більше трьох місяців, відколи Володимир Зеленський оголосив про контрнаступ України на півдні.
Тут, на Миколаївщині, тривають активні бойові дії, постійно працює ворожа артилерія, розповідають українські військові.
Вони запевняють, що понад усе прагнуть наступу. Адже швидше звільнення українських територій означає для воїнів повернення додому.
Я би хотів завтра зупинитися в Ялті, завтра побувати в Ялті. В українській Ялті. Але я розумію, що це не зовсім реальна мрія.
Треба почекати трошки довше. Ми хочемо якомога швидше закінчити ці всі процеси. Але якщо потрібно, то будемо тут і зимою, і весною, і літом.
Будемо стояти стільки, скільки треба для того, щоб повністю витіснити ворога з української землі.
Наступ ЗСУ на півдні був не такими видовищним і стрімким, як на Харківщині.
Але протягом останніх тижнів на цьому напрямку українська армія теж змогла досягти певного успіху.
Офіційні зведення - лаконічні. Але йдеться про просування на 10-20 кілометрів, десятки звільнених населених пунктів.
Українські військові певні: їхня тактика більш ефективна й виважена, ніж російська.
Але це не означає, що наступ схожий на легку прогулянку. Боєць із позивним "Комендант" воював в зоні АТО з 2014 року.
Він говорить, що ця війна кардинально відрізняється, але тактика ворога не змінилася.
Вони нахабно лізуть, лізуть і лізуть. Вони на свої втрати не зважають. Таке враження, що їм на своїх людей глибоко…
У нашій ситуації, саме тут, на нашому напрямку кожна душа нам реально потрібна. Жертвувати кимось нам не можна взагалі.
За словами "Коменданта", подекуди з ворогом доводиться зустрітися віч-на-віч.
Противник підійшов до нас на відстань витягнутої руки. Така собі була розвідка боєм, але ми успішно цю атаку відбили.
Противник зазнав доволі великих втрат. Один із них, вони не встигли його забрати нам довелося його поховати, по-християнськи.
Будьмо людьми. Навіть на війні потрібно знати, що то теж людина, хоч і ворог нам.
Села на під'їздах до лінії фронту постійно опиняються під обстрілами. Через це село російські війська пройшли на початку війни маршем.
Згодом цією ж дорогою росіяни відступили до Снігурівки.
Відколи територія опинилася під контролем України, вона перебуває під постійним вогнем російських снарядів.
У селі живуть до трьох десятків людей. Деякі починають повертатися, адже ситуація вже спокійніша.
Хата була геть уся понівечена. Оце шифером з обломків збирав. Коли довелося тоді…
Як рвонуло, я думав і хата підлетить. Я потім зразу поїхав, а потім кажуть, наче тихіше стало.
Я приїхав. Перекрили дах, бо дощі починали іти. Ну і так і вирішив залишитися.
Росія зазнала величезних втрат - і живої сили, і озброєння.
Через це Володимир Путін почав часткову мобілізацію. Українських захисників таке підсилення ворога не лякає.
Вони можуть набирати, кого хочуть і скільки хочуть. Але їхній моральний стан, ставлення місцевого населення до них їм не дозволяє бути розслабленими.
Військові кажуть, що зброї і припасів не бракує - і вітчизняних, і західних.
Перевага російської армії в техніці, за словами українських вояків, не означає перевагу на полі бою.
Кількість зброї у противника - так, суттєво більша. Але треба розуміти, що ми стоїмо на своїй землі.
Найсучасніший танк, найсучасніша керована ракета не спрацює без людини.
Для того, щоб людина натиснула на спусковий гачок, вона повинна мати мотивацію. Ми захищаємо свою українську, рідну землю.
Нині українські військові готуються до зими. Для цього потрібен не лише теплий одяг, а й зовсім інше маскування.
Треба налагодити логістику, обслуговування техніки.
Військові сподіваються, що зможуть звільнити якомога більше територій, поки погода дозволяє це зробити.